the threat over the great steel works at
Scunthorpe has hovered here for the last
decade but it's now reached another
pinch point British steel needs a 75
million pound bailout if it's not
forthcoming
insolvency planners are on standby it's
been an ongoing issue uncertainty with
jobs production and a lot of staff area
probably a bit used to it and a bit numb
to it I'd say you'd look after other
countries give it bailing them out work
out the bales up the name British steel
goes back decades
skilled pioneered by Britain more than a
century of though manufacture and
application of steel in quantity but
after privatization and buyouts Tartar
sold it for just a pound in 2016 a new
start for an old name over 4,000 workers
turn out some of the best steel in the
world here that has built everything
from the new airport in Istanbul to the
Border's railway in southern Scotland
but orders have slowed in recent months
particularly from Europe in response the
company pinpointed the uncertainties
around brexit as a major problem for the
entire industry
they said conversations are ongoing to
try to secure the finance for a viable
future here the unions are part of those
meetings on the line is this business
this industry this proud industry that
is the great steel maker in the world as
I believe and quite rightly so I think
those things have got to be protected
we've got to protect thousands of
workers and many many more thousands in
the supply chain which is the heart of
this town Scunthorpe voted to leave the
EU so did dawn read her grandfather
worked at the steel works her grandson
is about to start there as an apprentice
it feels like people are going to lose
the jobs again but the children because
the people that took over from Tata have
done their damnedest to keep that steel
where it's going I live up there in
those flats on the 15th floor that's my
view every morning and it breaks my art
thing
my grandparents and my dad and
everything worked all the lives on there
and it might not be there one day steel
towns across the UK have lurched from
crisis to crisis over the past decade
they need help they need proper strategy
for this week's problems and the
long-term future they still believe in
Tom Parmenter sky news Scunthorpe